oh boy here we go hi everyone my name is
Tamara chambers hello my name is Taylor
Taylor and this is Tamara just saw this
is super late and this movie came out
forever ago but I wanted to see it and
so we just saw the shape of water the
story is about a fish monster that was
heavily based off of the creature and
the first original creature the Black
Lagoon it's about a woman who cleans in
the facility that the fish monster is
being held and her story of finding love
with this fish monster I had a friend of
mine who I was hanging out with so we're
back home for the holidays and her
parents got back from seeing it when I
was still over there and they were like
it was unsettling for sure and I so
understand that people don't love it or
if they find it I'm settling or weird
because it was it was unsettling and
weird it was very dark I loved it I
loved the movie I thought it was so cool
it was such a good story for like
misfits and it was just really beautiful
and like it was this horrifying fairy
tale but the acting was incredible it
was really well cast well cast yeah for
sure
I loved that the lead was not like
Hollywood like classically you like
beautiful right she's cute she was so
cute and within like finding her
character she became even cuter and more
attractive I loved that she had this
like band of misfits that were friends
like a gay man in the 60s and a black
woman and then she falls in love with a
fish fish monster I think it was quite
the band of misfits all joining together
to make this happen he kept it like hard
enough in my opinion that I knew that
that was gonna end up that way I was
like okay it felt very Pan's Labyrinth
but darker and more gruesome but there's
a softness to his films that are like
this is fine and the music
really accompanies it well yeah you're
right okay cuz cuz I was thinking where
you said that about like the fingers
being ripped off and like the really
racist shadow the cross spoiler spoiler
rips fingers that but fish monster eats
to his fingers up rose and then they
show his fingers back on in hopes that
they will take but they don't take and
they throughout the film get darker and
darker darker as he gets darker and
darker and darker you know this is gonna
happen because you know you just know it
is but he's like this fingers a
representation of the man who once was
before this fish came into his life I
was really enjoying it sitting next to
my mom and I was just like oh don't work
the fingers off just from my mom saying
oh don't put him on think about the
mayor's IOP she loved it I really like
the Gil Marx and I love that that she is
like this seemingly so unimportant like
she she's a cleaner at this facility and
she's mute and she's not like this
Hollywood starlet and and and she's like
the princess of the goddamn sea and I
think it's a really nice how they how
they made her so important and so
special and beautiful while not at all
she was very sexually driven though oh
yeah there's two seas where she
masturbates in a tub he wasn't though
for sure no Seamus also I think it's
really cool that she masturbated in a
tub of water twice both times in water
because she was so connected to water
water and like that it drove her and she
was connected to it and I love that that
was the choice cuz it wasn't to show you
that she's like sexually driven or like
she needs to find a mate or like she
just you know is promiscuous outside of
her own like crudely manner and work it
was to show that she's like drawn to
water and like she needed that I loved
it wet joke
all right well okay so we're done here
he's another guy the fish monster was
awesome his design was super cool his
eyelids closing sideways was super cool
brother screaming syriza he's really
he's uh he becomes Abe from cowboy oh
yeah yeah yeah for sure I I wrote John I
don't think it's for everyone some
aspects but I mean yeah but like it's
artistically dying and it's like you get
emotionally connected they decide that
if somebody else is going to find this
fish monster that they should just cut
it open find that they can then dispose
of it so no one else gets its secrets so
she is now on a mission to save the fish
monster and she just like her will
misfit tag team gets it done and Ben
he's living in her house for a while and
then she has sex with it not mossy water
it's gonna be moss in gross loss in
gross losting that's just smells so bad
in there so they were trying to figure
out who stole the beast and one of the
lines is this guy's like I think it took
at least ten men to do it and mom like
loudly was like takes ten men what it
takes one woman to do tell mom that's
right now it's ten people every single
one of them know that tastes
I know this is late I know that probably
the people who like really wanted to see
this have already seen it but I loved it
I loved it more than Pan's Labyrinth
which I really loved
I thought it was I loved the weirdness I
love a good dark love story would you
recommend this to people uh certain
people yeah I would recommend this to
people I think it's really good I think
it's weird you feel weird while you're
watching it in the best way I think I
liked it I liked the movie it was a good
movie like it did a good job
[Laughter]
yeah I mean something can be well made
and really well done which it was
without you like what are people to
liking it any kind of truth that you can
like unveil like in an honest way mm-hmm
it's uncomfortable at Bart's it's funny
parts it's you know it's what this movie
was there's all those kind of things
it's beautiful shota showed a very very
bear part of like human Yamma psyche and
like what the need to be wanted and like
all that but then there's that one
little praise like yeah she's gonna
finish it's like weird it's just odd
it's like but but if you can get over
that it's a nice movie feel like it was
mostly weird for me just because I've
said my mom we were all there Alone's
the acting I love the characters I feel
like the three main characters were so
good and so well developed Oh a part
that you didn't like though that I
really liked is the dancing part
the dancing sequence I thought I just it
took me out of it oh there's a part
where they're sitting at a table the
fish monster and her and which is sort
of breaking out she knows that he has to
go back into the ocean so she's gonna
release him into the ocean and she wants
to tell him that she loves him and he's
looking down eating eggs so in her mind
she says I love you and then she breaks
out into this song and dance and the
whole film they had been watching her in
her neighborhood and watching older
films of like dancing stars and singing
stars very glamorous beautiful dresses
and in that moment to tell this grand
gesture in her mind she can sing and she
can like vocalize things even though
she's mute and she's in this beautiful
dress and she's beautiful and she's
dancing with the fish monster and it was
I mean I loved it I thought it was good
I thought it was such a wonderful like
declaration of love I don't really know
too much about the director
and so I at that particular moment when
she started bursting out and just song I
didn't know I was for like two seconds I
was like just gonna go to two ways like
I wanted to it either it went the way it
went and this is just like this is how
she yeah this is like a fantasy like oh
my god this is how like it's just so
epic and like lovely and all this it's
swelling and it's like beautiful in the
dancing it's a little silly but it's
like fun
yeah or this is the start of like a
movie shifting event where she starts to
like tille off like the sandy skills
like it's you like certainly get hostile
for like the finisher more and like like
yeah and I thought I was gonna like he'd
go that way I was like oh man
cuz we've like we've all been
empathizing with this girl so what she's
actually like what does two suns
actually going like crazy right oh my
god oh man oh so you just said it's the
start and I just immediately thought you
were gonna go into High School Musical
it's the start of something new it feels
so right to be here with you Oh
[Music]
thank you so much for watching we'll see
you all next week bye
you